do i like karaoke i'm filipino my
umbilical cord was a microphone wire
hi i'm joe and i'm about to fill my
online shopping cart mom can i use your
credit card
mom
[Music]
the kohler newmie intelligent toilet for
seven thousand dollars this is a smart
toilet a bidet this is gonna clean yo
ass
first of all it's square hello how cool
is that i love everything square lets
you set
every detail to your personal preference
ah you like that warm seat you can do it
it has built-in amazon alexa
and if you're a conspiracy theorist
that's kind of cool
hey alexa yes joe
enjoy that government
oh yeah man
karaoke usa
karaoke machine
so good they used the word karaoke twice
i love that picture of the the the
person singing
bluetooth wireless speaker all in one
media player digital color screen led
lights that synchronize and flash with
the rhythm of the music man they
shouldn't have bluetooth this one this
thing looks so old everything should
plug in they should have a cassette
the lg styler smart closet with true
steam technology for 1300
what
this is sick you don't want to wash it
but you kind of wore it a couple of
times but you need to get some wrinkles
out but you want it to smell good this
is what you use right here
you can put like perfume whatever
perfume that you use and put it in their
filter or you could just put like a like
a like a sheet of
bounce or something in there right and
you just press the button
steams it out makes it smell good and
makes it smell fresh this right here is
a top contender for my cart i love it
it's a great idea i hate to iron and i
hate to wash
next up the sony ibo companion robot
three thousand dollars man for an ai dog
imagine someone breaking into your house
and your ai dog attacks it
i want a real dog dogs take in emotion
they suck the pain out of your body you
know what i mean they're the best
therapy they know when you're sad they
know when you're happy they know when
you're mad and they don't give a [ __ ]
i bow
i think it's obvious you guys i think
the smartest thing here to get
is the lg styler smart closet i think
it's a brilliant idea there's a lot of
lazy people out there that know what i'm
talking about and this
is the perfect lazy man's gadget add to
cart
now we're going to watches
dang
diesel this is the mr daddy 2.0 57
millimeters bro lots of watch for your
money
bro it's got buttons and [ __ ] two arms
black with screws
rubber band
so you can jump into [ __ ] this watch
right here you have to drive a huge
truck i mean you can't get into a huge
truck with a small watch you need a
watch that looks like your truck you can
get shot in the wrist and guess what
that bullet will not penetrate this
[ __ ] watch you ever see wonder woman
block bullets and [ __ ]
this is a rolex moonface 39 millimeter
okay look if you're a rolex guy this is
the one you get they have a lot of
features on these watches and i don't
even know
what they do
yes there's a moon that moves with the
real moon
guess what
not too many uh rolex people carry these
in the store i would buy it for 26 7.
this is a good deal i would buy this
this is something you give your your kid
when he gets married or
you know
this is a beautiful piece oh my god this
is sick man
the casio data bank vintage calculator
watch 24 39.
when i was a kid i used to get jealous
when i saw kids wearing this on their
wrist bro especially during math tests
just looking at him he's just like this
looking at the teacher
got it they said that this is great to
calculate tips at restaurants first of
all if you need help calculating tips
you need more than a watch audemars 41
millimeter i mean beautiful right solid
gold with the green face it's half a
million let's not even [ __ ] with 465
000 i think once you get to like four
something just say half a million
let's stop i don't think if you're
buying a watch at 465 000 if they put
500 000 on i don't think they're gonna
be like
um look people are gonna hate on me but
i i am very biased with my watches i
love rolex and if it comes to a green
face i already got mine i got the
stainless steel hulk you can't get that
nowhere
i mean it's obvious which one is the get
and that's the moon face rolex 26 000
that's a steal believe me
it's an investment it can only go up
from here everyone's going to say that
the automars is the investment no it's
not for 465 000
buy a condo adding to the cart the moon
face
26 000
i'll spend a couple extra grand for it
too
oh
yes
my favorite part cars this is the hummer
the brand new gmc hummer ev 112 000
great price point wow the body shape is
pretty dope this looks like they're
trying to compete with the new bronco
this is electric 0 to 60 in three
seconds
vegan interior that's pretty cool for a
hummer my electric car is pescatarian
look at this man it crab walks it moves
diagonally in either direction with
four-wheel steering that's dope man so
we can just go right into the slot you
don't have to worry about backing up
nope one more time this will park your
car perfectly every time that my friend
is worth 112 000 dollars honestly i'll
think about it and then there's a kia
soul if that's what you want then get it
who doesn't want their car to have a
little soul 19 000 i mean it gets you
from point a to point b it's a beautiful
car i mean this was your this is your
first car when you're like 18 years old
right get that
ooh wow this is the spider this is the
ultimate sports car right here it's just
beautiful everything about it is
beautiful like the the engine's
beautiful the body's beautiful the
interior is beautiful it really is a
work of art i love the spider my son
loves the the spider i think it's
beautiful but i bought the portofino
it's that's my thing i love it it's just
like when you get my age the
the spider is just that's a young guy
sports car portofino is that that
driving
you know cruising ferrari you know i
mean but still got the power i'll blow
all you out the water so don't think you
guys can beat me i'll kill you you have
an electric hummer i got you
the 2022
hyundai
santa cruz
sel
this is this is actually very pretty you
know what i love about the santa cruz
is it's got the old-school look like the
the el camino you remember the old el
camino it's like a car but a truck you
don't know what it was
this one has that that look and i love
it
good looking car man hyundai makes good
cars they really do i'm not gonna lie
yeah i think it's obvious what i'm
throwing into my shopping cart you guys
it's the ferrari spider
[Music]
moving on to coffee
uh the copico instant premium three in
one coffee for 9.99 let me tell you
something as a child of an immigrant
mother
this
is top shelf coffee my mom loves this
stuff instant
just like that put it in a cup add some
water delicious joseph you're going to
love this coffee
it's so good and you get 30 of them wow
you get 30 packs
yeah this is a good deal
let's keep moving on that's bringing me
back to my childhood
dolce gabbana just did a collabo with
smeg
what this espresso machine is gangster i
love everything smeg does everything
they do they got that 50s style
throwback this is a piece right i want
it i'm buying this i don't even want to
look at anything else this one is the
coolest for 1500
this is beautiful
wait is my coffee in here you know i own
my own coffee right hey
you know what i found a bag of coffee
that i want to buy right here
look at this
coj cup of joe that's right chicory
flavored coffee little tiny chicory
chips it's such a great smelling and
great tasting full cup of coffee
and this is my coffee i'm the one that
came up with this one i tasted so many
different
beans and everything and i specifically
had a taste in mine
and we got it right yep for 23 what a
bargain i'm gonna put 12 of these bags
in my cart right now the jura giga six
automatic coffee machine for 5999
whoo
i thought it was gonna be six g's but
it's not yeah it's worth it i mean
you're getting premium
quality
coffee
i mean this is gonna taste just like a a
barista made it for you in the
convenience of your own home um you know
what you guys i'm gonna go ahead and add
two things to my shopping cart one is
the obvious right cup of joe
but what's coffee without an espresso
machine and if you're gonna get one get
something that's like a work of art dng
killed it with this meg collabo so for
fifteen hundred dollars it's a huge yes
and moving on
luggage
the gucci double g supreme you can wear
sweats with this bag you can wear a suit
with this bag you can wear a polo and
some shorts with this bag this bag
compliments anything
all right this is this is a beautiful
bag this really is the remo off-white
it's a see-through case it's 1700 that's
actually a get don't get me wrong it's
super fly it's just it's not convenient
wherever you're traveling to
it's gonna be packed very well it's
gonna look beautiful in your suitcase
damn he folded his t-shirts when you
come back from vegas he's gonna be like
yo did he throw up on that shirt
did he [ __ ] on those boxers next
24 thousand dollars for this bag yes
this is a collector's piece that's all
this is it's not even to like travel
with i have a lot of supreme louie right
i got the whole camo set i got the
jacket i got the backpack the fanny pack
the duffel
i got everything
man
i was gonna say no but now i keep
looking at it and yeah this is a get
you got to get this
uh there's one more and it is the july
carry-on trunk
great value at 345 dollars the cool
thing about the july carry-on truck is
it has the ports it has every port that
you need a usb port android apple
whatever you need to plug into this
thing you can do it and you just plug it
right back into the wall and recharge
the battery it's got a beautiful power
source right off to the side of the uh
the handle i like this bag
i'm still getting the supreme
louis vuitton supreme bag is going right
into the cart
and that's it you guys i had a blast i
think my favorite item out of the whole
thing
that rolex and then my second favorite
thing would be the smeg
espresso machine i think my least
favorite would have to be anything with
rosemary
you